david rigoulet roze rédacteur en chef de
la revue orient stratégie bonsoir david
rigoulet roze merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france les états unis donc
les grands absents on vient d'en parler
de ces pourparlers washington qui évoque
des raisons logistiques son autre
justification se doute évidemment que ce
n'est pas là la cause principale
non c'est un prétexte effectivement
d'ailleurs assez peu convaincante comme
vous l'avez fait remarquer c'est à dire
que la situation
s'y prêtait pas vraiment les américains
n'avaient pas envie se retrouver avec
une délégation à moscou en dépit
l'application formelle qui avaient été
faites à washington
parce que ben y'a rien quand même il
faut digérer le retrait qui a été pour
le moins chaotique en plus il ya vous
l'avez évoqué également il ya l annonce
de la démission de zalmay khalilzad qui
était celui qui avait négocié l'accord
de retrait justement et qui a reconnu en
grande partie l'échec puisque ce qui
avait été attendu les attendus de cet
accord n'ont pas été pour le moins
couronnés de succès en tout cas en terme
de d'inclusivité gouvernementales et de
et de d'engagement par rapport aux
risques terroristes donc d'une certaine
manière les america's mettait ce préféré
rester hors jeu entre guillemets par
rapport à ce qu'il fait figure de
formats moscovite sur l'afghanistan
depuis plusieurs années et qui regroupe
les pays régionaux il ya une
régionalisation réalité de la structure
moscovite qui laisse un peu les
américains de côté alors qu'à pâton
maintenant justement attendre de cette
rencontre
on sait que ce sont les questions
sécuritaires notamment et humanitaire
qui vont être abordés oui alors on
affiche agi à la dimension humanitaire
puisque la russie s'est proposé pour
pour assurer effectivement
un approvisionnement humanitaire
d'urgence mais sur le fond c'est la
préoccupation centrale c'est la question
sécuritaire d'ailleurs les dernières
déclarations du président poutine sur le
risque constitué par l'état vis à vis de
khorasan par rapport justement au aux
engagements talibans montre bien que
c'est la préoccupation principale de ce
format qui rudy les pays régionaux en
l'occurrence la chine qui est très
préoccupé également évidemment les pays
d'aix
union soviétique d'asie centrale pour
lesquelles moscou à une attention toute
particulière l'inde le pakistan donc on
voit bien que ce sont tous les pays qui
sont
de l'afghanistan il n'est pas question
qu'un regain d'histoire ou des outils et
si le problème pour situation actuelle
on sait qu'il y avait déjà eu un sommet
d'autres sommets à organiser notamment
en mars dernier avec toujours cette
inquiétude quant aux hauts risques
terroristes
est-ce qu'il est réel david rigoulet
roze justement pour la russie y est et
ses voisins d'avis ah oui les réelles
d'ailleurs les derniers attentats le
pauvre effectivement il ya une
recrudescence d'attentats revendiqués
par l'état islamique du khorassan qui la
branche locale de l'état islamique
contre plusieurs mosquées avec des
dizaines de morts donc ça pose le
problème de la crédibilité sécuritaire
justement du gouvernement taliban et
cesser ce qui est pour eux un problème
majeur parce que il avait fondé la
légitimité de justement de deux de leurs
installations en grande partie sur cette
crédibilité sécuritaire et sur des
engagements qu'ils auraient pris non
seulement vis-à-vis des américains mais
également vis-à-vis des russes lors le
passage à moscou à plusieurs reprises
2-2 d'éradiquer effectivement le danger
terroriste et puis de clarifier leurs
relations avec des groupes évidemment
l'historiquement al qaïda et puis des
des groupes périphériques qui ont été
liés à un moment ou un autre justement à
la mouvance talibane
ce qui préoccupe les chinois notamment
le tous ceux qui sont dans la mouvance
djihadiste ouïghours notamment mais pas
seulement donc c'est toute la fragilité
de l'asie centrale qui posait la
question sécuritaire dont pour les
russes et les pays d'asie centrale la
question des droits des respect humain
toujours un souci premier pour les
occidentaux est-ce que cela reste
finalement
crédible comme comme ceux ci à résoudre
aujourd'hui où finalement l'urgence nict
d'autres sujets
il ya une dichotomie assez nette entre
jaillir la posture des occidentaux de
manière assez large et puis les pays
régionaux qui sont concernés au premier
chef
pour ce qui est des occidentaux ya
effectivement des exigences en matière
de droits humains notamment par rapport
aux femmes aux filles l'accès à
l'éducation en particulier et donc il ya
une forme de conditionnalité
notamment par rapport à une
reconnaissance éventuelle du
gouvernement taliban qui a été posée
c'est moins le cas du côté des pays
justement du format moscovite parce
qu'ils sont leurs priorités premières
c'est évidemment de souhaiter un
gouvernement inclusif mai mais surtout
par rapport à des enjeux sécuritaires
qui sont qui jouxte leur frontière donc
la position est pas tout à fait la même
même si évidemment la question de la
reconnaissance ne pourra pas se faire
sans qu'il y ait un consensus
international minimale merci beaucoup
david arrigo les onze d'avoir été avec
nous et nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage ce soir